time for our next caller we've got joe
on the line
how are you joe i'd be a hell of a lot
better but carol would get off my ass
it sounds like you two know each other
you know they say that cub breeders are
evil
that we get rid of our animals after
they're
old and expensive have you ever seen me
do that
well i just started here no
i got big plans i'm gonna take my tour
national
so the whole world can love all my
beautiful babies
cause that's what i'm about
my kids love me just as much as
i love them
wanna see some [ __ ]
yeah
my dream
is always
to have a zoo you wanna know why
yeah
because why would i wanna have
a regular job
when i can do this
what the [ __ ]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
you got a deal
oh
don't ask me
she's the boss
if you're having second thoughts there's
a roadside zoo up in tennessee that'll
take him
him
it's
i'm sorry it's a it's a girl
cat weighs 450 easy yeah but the um the
paws are too small and there's no rough
around the neck
plus she's got a vagina
if you look
oh man
it's okay
sweetheart
we're gonna get you out of here
it's okay
well
okay so you said 5 000.
gonna need 10.
now
hold on just a minute this cat is
purebred siberian
uh-huh oh
my gosh i didn't know
shoot
okay can i see your permit then
because you're selling her across state
lines and the endangered species act
says you need a permit if it's a
purebred so
i'm sure you know that
if you want i can um get fish and
wildlife to come down and
help us sort this out what's your
problem lady
my problem is
that i would like one day of peace on
this earth sir
but i can't have it because i keep
having to get into fights with men like
you
you